at first high security forces have
stormed a mall to help hundreds of
people escape a hostage situation a
soldier had shot and killed 20 people
before holding others in the shopping
center in the city of Kurata just
northeast of the capital Bangkok
witnesses say the shooter has an assault
rifle well let's circle live now it's
Wayne hey he joins us from Bangkok when
just bring us up to speed on the latest
in that situation has it had been
brought to a close
it hasn't according to the latest update
we've received from the police also the
Defense Ministry giving a regular
updates at a location near the mall the
shooter is still believed to be inside
that shopping mall in the city of korat
where he has been for several hours and
the police confirming that there are
hostages they believe being kept by the
gunman somewhere inside the mall they're
not sure exactly how many hostages there
are in there and it seems that there is
also some confusion about exactly where
he may be inside the mall what they are
saying is that police soldiers as well
have gone inside the building itself and
have managed to secure several of the
floors within the mall obviously those
floors and not where the shooter is he
is still in there somewhere
exactly where if they know the police
are not saying so again this has been
going on for several hours began
mid-afternoon on Saturday on an army
base he is a serving member of the Thai
military he shot at least three people
are on the military base before driving
in a stolen army vehicle towards the
city center towards the mall where we
now know he went in many more shots were
fired inside the mall and now it appears
the situation is still ongoing with
again hostages being held by the gunman
and we just give us some context here
how unusual is this type of incident in
Thailand it's pretty unusual for a
shooting to happen on this scale
certainly we see them
fairly regularly on a smaller scale than
this it has to be said in the
southernmost provinces of Thailand three
southernmost provinces that border
Malaysia that is where there is an armed
separatist movement so there are regular
attacks staged in those provinces
against security forces against other
symbols of the the state of the
government in Bangkok but certainly of
this nature it is not common gun
ownership is fairly common in Thailand
and therefore gun-related crime
gun-related violence is also fairly
common but again not on the scale it
also has to be pointed out the army is a
very large factor entire society it is
very present it is a very large military
about 350,000 also serving as full-time
soldiers within the Thai military so
it's fairly big and quite often there
are reports of weapons that go missing
from army bases the weapons storage
facilities are often broken into and a
lot of weapons do go missing again this
shooter is believed to be a serving
member of the Thai Army as so is likely
to ever had access to many different
types of weapons and according to
unconfirmed reports he has more than one
gun on him inside the mall where that
situation as is ongoing okay when Hey
Efrain out thank you